We end this lecture sequence
by stepping back to discuss
what probability theory really
is and what exactly is the
meaning of the word
probability.
In the most narrow view,
probability theory is just a
branch of mathematics.
We start with some axioms.
We consider models that satisfy
these axioms, and we
establish some consequences,
which are the
theorems of this theory.
You could do all that without
ever asking the question of
what the word "probability"
really means.
Yet, one of the theorems of
probability theory, that we
will see later in this class,
is that probabilities can be
interpreted as frequencies,
very loosely speaking.
If I have a fair coin, and I
toss it infinitely many times,
then the fraction of
heads that I will
observe will be one half.
In this sense, the probability
of an event, A, can be
interpreted as the frequency
with which event A will occur
in an infinite number of
repetitions of the experiment.
But is this all there is?
If we're dealing with coin
tosses, it makes sense to
think of probabilities
as frequencies.
But consider a statement such
as the "current president of
my country will be reelected
in the next election with
probability 0.7".
It's hard to think of this
number, 0.7, as a frequency.
It does not make sense to
think of infinitely many
repetitions of the
next election.
In cases like this, and in many
others, it is better to
think of probabilities
as just some way of
describing our beliefs.
And if you're a betting person,
probabilities can be
thought of as some numerical
guidance into what kinds of
bets you might be
willing to make.
But now if we think of
probabilities as beliefs, you
can run into the argument
that, well, beliefs are
subjective.
Isn't probability theory
supposed to be an objective
part of math and science?
Is probability theory just an
exercise in subjectivity?
Well, not quite.
There's more to it.
Probability, at the minimum,
gives us some rules for
thinking systematically about
uncertain situations.
And if it happens that our
probability model, our
subjective beliefs, have some
relation with the real world,
then probability theory can be
a very useful tool for making
predictions and decisions that
apply to the real world.
Now, whether your predictions
and decisions will be any good
will depend on whether you
have chosen a good model.
Have you chosen a model that's
provides a good enough
representation of
the real world?
How do you make sure that
this is the case?
There's a whole field, the field
of statistics, whose
purpose is to complement
probability theory by using
data to come up with
good models.
And so we have the following
diagram that summarizes the
relation between the real
world, statistics, and
probability.
The real world generates data.
The field of statistics and
inference uses these data to
come up with probabilistic
models.
Once we have a probabilistic
model, we use probability
theory and the analysis tools
that it provides to us.
And the results that we get
from this analysis lead to
predictions and decisions
about the real world.